excellent show tonight we're gonna have
a good time I somebody during the
commercial break you didn't see it
somebody dropped off a card or something
for you there and I thought you might
want to look at it that's weird
yeah this out I'm not sure what it is
it's got the Trump logo on Rob Lowe
though yeah it's got the Trump logo I'm
holding it to one of three cameras and
then are taking a close-up that's weird
the logo is not that good yeah close
this is weird I don't know what it is
looks like this is weird it looks like
an invitation from Donald Trump
what yeah oh dear Hollywood notable I
would be honored if you could perform at
my inauguration January 20th
if you can't make it print 10 copies of
this loan and mail them to 10 other
Hollywood notables failure the said dead
copies of this letter will bring you bad
luck Vanessa Hudgens broke the chain and
she wound up getting attacked by a shark
so your your choices perform at my
inauguration to make ten copies of this
invitation and send them to your
Hollywood house three can attack by a
shark see you in Washington Donald J
Trump
for a Z's nuts well what are you gonna
do do I'm not gonna do anything okay
forget it I'm not doing this I'm not
afraid of sharks plus it's winter I'm
not going near the ocean any time soon
I'm safe
[Music]
appearing this Friday at the Trump
inauguration Conan O'Brien and his
puppet chatters why did it shatter well
not a lot of people know this but sharks
are made of fiber yeah all right
you